today's topic Jake Paul now I can't
stand this dude y'all know how I feel I
don't like watching his content I think
he's a goober that being said he was
caught at the protests and what ended up
happening was that he was caught
apparently looting so we're gonna take a
look at the footage and then we're gonna
respond any some water for this one
that's dry Jake Paul says he and his
team did not participate in looting and
vandalism at an arizona mall video of
the youtube star and his team members at
the Scottsdale Fashion Square was posted
to instagram by andrew blue who claims
to be Logan's videographer the video
shows people breaking windows of the
shopping center outside it also shows
what happened inside including people
smashing the windows of a display car
you are a selfish cloud chaser I don't
see how this is any better than what his
brother did in that sight force I
genuinely don't if using a situation in
the club it's not a thing degree but it
comes from the same place in your head
bro go ahead I think it's worse oh
because there's a thing when Logan went
to the force and he filmed a dead body
right there's nobody else's him and his
team they filmed it yeah okay it might
encourages fans who watch the video
later but there's nobody other can do so
no bad but when you film people rioting
and looting and they're handing you
stuff you're encouraging them to
perpetuate that destructive behavior is
it not worse Matt logically speaking is
it not worse maybe I'm messing yeah
maybe you're missing it but you got a
and he's fortunate that there's so much
other bull going on right now and so
much others recover that no one's coming
down on him but to me this is worse yeah
I see what you're saying guys we don't
know how YouTube's gonna react to these
videos they D monetizing monetizing
things it's been super confusing for me
so if you want to ensure that this video
does well please hit the like button it
helps us out a like comment help with
all that algorithm stuff and yeah we
also have a patreon you can check out so
if you want to see more of us we have a
podcast there there was some protests
going on here and I need to go
because pre shirts because you're not
black [ __ ] was about to have an
existential crisis but not damn Joe
Biden was right to be absolutely clear
neither I nor anyone in our group was
engaged in any looting or vandalism
which I don't believe whatsoever but at
the same time
let's say he's right let's say they were
just there filming and documenting and
people were giving them bottle because
it was Jake Paul do you not recognize
how your presence endorses that kind of
behavior
do you not realize how you standing
there and running around filming these
people and giving them club because you
accuse a lot of people being cloud
chasers that people want to get famous
so they'll do anything on camera
do you not recognize how you filming
them also endorses what they're doing
what they put is a part in the video
where they are storming a Sephora okay
you sure pulled it up and entering a
Sephora through the broken glass door
hey yo give me a free pillow is that him
that's the guy that posted it that's I
gotta film it real now he said nobody of
this group fair engage in that mmm
nobody of his group it's his group its
his entourage videographer yes yeah get
me a cologne in there you are a selfish
cloud chaser so indirectly whether you
realize it or not you are doing that and
when you're filming this stuff what are
you gonna put it online on YouTube you
know check it out we're at this right so
now you're gonna send this message to
all your young viewers that you think is
just really nearly to go to some right
and just sit there and film people and
encourage them and that way indirectly
do you not recognize what kind of
responsibility that you have in that
regards like what are you thinking
but then again this is the same Paul
brother that who who received boxing
training and thought it would be funny
to block somebody who's never boxed on
camera for views Eric decided today he
wanted to challenge you to a boxing
match or the surprise
[Music]
for context we spent the day doing our
most our part to peacefully protest one
of the most horrific and justices in our
country has ever seen which led to us
being tear gassed for filming the events
and brutality that were unfolding in
Arizona first off you know he didn't
write this yo you know cuz the way I
with his ten IQ could not have written
this first off he mumbles through all of
his talks he's incoherent you want me to
believe that this man wrote this come on
now there's nothing worse than somebody
else writing your apology it just reeks
of insincerity
but that is when Jake Paulus he's an
insincere person so let's keep going
we were gassed and forced to keep moving
on foot we filmed everything we saw in
an effort to share our experience and
bring more attention to the anger felt
in every neighborhood we travel through
that's not Jay Paul Jake Paul's team
issued an apology yeah yeah we were
strictly document acknowledging I do not
condone violence in looting but you do
film it and encourage it okay good to
know or breaking the law however I
understand the anger and frustration
that led to the destruction we witness
and while it's not the answer it's
important that people see it and
collectively figure out how to move
forward in a healthy way
oh my god I [ __ ] up so bad bro this is
not an apology this dude's a straight-up
Clapton this goober is not apologizing
he's saying we did nothing wrong and by
the way let me virtue signal by telling
you I understand your anger but breath
you didn't write this these are not your
views up or if they are you didn't
expose them in your words and you're not
even apologizing for your involvement
what the yes can you explain why he's a
clown though explain it who else am I
gonna call the clown you get on Twitter
after you're called out for filming
people doing the lunate if you say you
didn't do it you just took the bottles
you received it okay I'll give you the
benefit of the doubt even though you
don't deserve it any type of wait you're
still a [ __ ] goober for being out
there and filming content do you know
how impressionable a lot of young people
are they see you putting a camera on
that what are they gonna do well some
people say that it's not his fault
sure doesn't change the fact that it's
irresponsible his brother didn't have
the responsibility not to film those
dead people in the forest but he still
did it and it's still reflected badly on
absolutely
there's still a responsibility to some
of this mm-hmm we're responsible I think
what some people are gonna say hey I'm
not being like hey listen if you
negligent you can get these hints
metaphorically which are words in this
case but you feel what I'm saying you
just catch these words there you go
words are fists in the right users hands
I understand the it's important that we
see it and collectively figure out how
to move forward a healthy way we're all
doing the best we can to be helpful and
raise awareness this is not the time to
attack each other is the time to join
together and evolve what a garbage
person yo man official clown license
belongs to you this is a clown and
here's the thing right do we see how
people act on camera you got a big
platform you like a what you guys doing
out there and you put the camera on them
you know they gonna go crazy now is it
your fault that they went crazy not
necessarily but you do bear some
responsibility encouraging that behavior
I'm not crazy for that because we know
how being observed affects the people
the cops when they're filmed they act
differently sometimes there is also
something really gross about rich
suburban nights during these rights so
they can loot and break stuff just
because they want to be part of
something and they want to break some
things that really doesn't fear me
because there's people on the ground who
are truly angrily and truly suffering
and who are trying to stop these people
and to know that you're not gonna be
impacted if these changes don't get put
into effect yet you want to impact the
movement really is gross there is
something disgusting about you
purposefully throwing yourself in
something that you have no stakes in and
really hurting the people who will
suffer from it the most and the fact
that you haven't apologized says a lot
about your care if you feel what I'm
saying you have no stakes in this so you
can act however you want you don't give
it well you're in it for you that's the
privilege right there it doesn't affect
you so you don't care you know at some
point on this channel it gets tiring to
have to cover like garbage human being
dubs the fire of you me the worst part
isn't the fact that he did what he did
the worst part is that he got on Twitter
and gave this bull letter condescending
to people the answer is this I is a 22
year old who really hasn't done much
suffering in life I'm going to tell you
how you solve this issue
you talking about I'm not gonna listen
to some suburbanite who lives up in the
hills trying to tell me what it takes to
solve this issue like what is you
talking about and I think my happiness
like it's really just okay this is gonna
be drawing attention to me cuz they've
been in you know negative attention
around them yeah they're used to it now
maybe the first time you were really
sorry because you thought it would
affect you but now you see now it was
not affecting you and wrong you do it
again you're gonna do it again
you can do it again do some more done
anyways that's it for today's video we
want to hear your thoughts let us know
do you guys agree with our take on this
we want to hear your comments but the
thing is I didn't go because it was
gonna be media there and you know
there's gonna be people filming and the
way they portrayed stuff is my face is
there they feel me next thing you know
oh look there was a lot of riots and my
face is on first page not my mama got a
heart attack
I can't go to the funerals because of
Cole vid it's up like you know what I
mean they could do whatever they want
with the pictures and all of that so I
like yeah I'm gonna stay away from that
I understand the people that went there
no I understand Haridas apology to be
clear to be absolutely clear neither I
nor anyone in our group was engaged in
any looting or him being there to film
it's like she has a rap sheet of being
some garbage dumpster fire this guy's
very good at looking like he's doing the
right thing but he's really not am I
surprised not really you know let's just
go with the track record you know of
what he's doing
Lemony Snicket's he's just a series of
unfortunate events that's him that's
that dude right there trying to profit
ate up a situation that's what's going
on yeah I use profit again that's what
it is to me it is a bad taste it's not
the worst thing that they've done I'm
not surprised at all